oh my goodness we got lots of good
sunshine out there and the leftover full
moon from earlier in the week hanging
out over the spring mountains it is
really really beautiful nice blue skies
temperatures kind of a mix of 40s and
some upper 30s so kids for sure you've
got to put on some jackets this morning
when you're heading out for school 40
degrees is the nice average but boy this
afternoon when that bell rings it is
time for a three-day weekend that's
right it's a holiday mid 60s today and
we are on a warming trend as we get into
the weekend so put that grill back on
get those dogs and burgers out we are
going to have some 70s for saturday and
sunday cooking up some wonderful weather
for the weekend southwest breezes could
get downright gusty for president's day
though as we'll look for the first of a
couple of systems to arrive yeah
temperatures aren't going to sizzle
they're going to fizzle i'm afraid once
we get into next week now these are all
the systems dropping out of the pacific
northwest from the gulf of alaska so
they're going to have cold air with them
again so enjoy the nice warmth across
the southwest mid 70s for la this
weekend mornings will get warmer too
to near 80 for phoenix both saturday and
sunday nice weekend and of course
they'll try to thaw out across the
mid-south the midwest where they had so
much snow and all of that big wind even
tornadoes suspected in alabama rain is
working its way off the east coast but
there could be some travel snarls today
because of those leftover snow showers
in that cold front 52 up on the mountain
look for temps in the mid to upper 50s
through the weekend as temperatures warm
up in the valley 66 today that's a
little above normal and then we slide
right into those 70's for the weekend
but the first changes appear sunday
night into monday with some of those
winds slight chance of showers in the
mountains maybe snow showers too monday
and then the second system chance of
rain for the valley maybe tuesday night
into wednesday and lower snow levels
because of the cold air in place highs
only in the 50s next week mornings near
freezing for